si ça n'arrive vraiment pas
Howard nazi
a une attaque chanceuse
as
[Musique]
dehors
des Comores
ou non
d'accord
wanda
de réduction et de chargement
on croit à la réflexion
je me suis arrêté à
de dit
estimé
Yo
[Musique]
ils étaient par derrière
jours de course
de lit
ils disent qu'ils sont atteints du syndrome
chrétien et banc
dit tout
[Musique]
chemin vers moi
mais il est fort alors
jouer
plus loin
[Musique]
Non
et
[Musique]
Oh
danse
[Musique]
nous
heidegger
maintenant
s'arrête enfin
etc.
pas préféré
bon
pour un produit
cospédale
le piano
levé est allé sortir
sur le bateau
beau
meilleurs amis
après avoir marché
transcendance
Cortez le grand
comme c'était le cas pour le chat mou externe
Peut
tiens ton esclave
peut-être que tu le feras
zone
de quoi
[Musique]